During
the direct message last week,
I mentioned how people from all over the
world watching and listening to the
Rubin report are connecting through the
power of ideas.
Immediately after we posted the video
online,
the comments section lit up with people
chiming in from around the globe.
For those of you keeping score,
here are the countries I heard from in
no particular order,
Macedonia,
Hungary,
Poland,
Lebanon,
Denmark,
Ukraine,
United Kingdom,
Finland,
United States,
Canada,
Italy,
Arac,
Slovakia,
Israel greased.
I won Germany,
Russia,
Switzerland,
Argentina,
Ireland,
Belgium,
Georgia,
Netherlands,
Bangladesh,
South Africa,
India and New Zealand,
Norway,
Brazil,
Australia,
Portugal,
Spain,
and even North Korea by my count.
That's 35 countries and that's just from
the people who happened to comment on
the video or tweet to me wherever you
are,
you are a living,
breathing example of why ideas about
secular values and free speech matter.
For my interviews to you guys,
furthering the conversations on social
media were igniting ideas and people all
over the world who share the same ideals
as the civil rights activist.
Medgar Evers said,
you can kill a man,
but you can't kill an idea,
so whether you're listening to this in
the comforts of your vacation home on
the Italian coast,
while on a bus in India or in an
apartment complex in war torn Iraq,
you're a piece of the puzzle of
reclaiming liberalism and having honest
conversations even with those whom we
disagree,
ideas of brought us together,
but I think we're just at the precipice
of what this conversation about free
speech and liberalism could become.
So now I want you guys to be part of the
show more than ever before.
I think we can do something bigger than
just emailing,
tweeting,
and facebooking.
I want to talk directly to you.
Consider this my official request to
have you.
Yeah,
you on the Rubin report.
We're going to take a group of five
viewers from five different countries
and I will interview you via skype for
10 minutes.
Posting them all as one complete
episode.
I want to know who you are,
what you do,
why you think the conversations we've
been having here are important,
and how you came to think the way you do
together.
I think we can amplify our message of
conversation,
human rights and secular values in an
exponential way.
I don't care if you're a religious
atheist,
Republican,
Democrat,
black,
white,
gay or straight.
What I care about is,
yeah,
you got it.
Your ideas with this in mind,
joining me this week are my friend and
former guests,
Feisal Syeda,
Al Mutar and first time guest,
Melissa Chen.
Feisal was born in Iraq and now lives in
New York where he works with
movements.org
and organization dedicated to helping
people escape closed societies.
Melissa is from Singapore,
got her phd at Mit and is the manager of
the global secular humanist movement.
These are two people who are using their
voices to help those who need it most,
and now it's time to make your voice
heard.
To go to Ora dot TV slash Rubin report
or click the link in the description
right down below and let us know why you
want to be on the Rubin report.
Oh,
in complementing the host probably won't
hurt your chances.
My guest this week,
our feisal site on Matar and Melissa
Chen,
they worked together at the global
secular humanist movement,
a platform committed to the use of
critical reason,
factual evidence and scientific methods
of inquiry rather than faith and
mysticism in seeking solutions to human
problems and answers to important human
questions.
That was a serious intro.
You guys write a nice boiler plate
there.
I got to tell you.
Well,
I tried my best.
You gave me all.
Those are all the buzzwords that we talk
about all the time,
right?
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
And,
and uh,
the word committed is the most important
one.
Committed,
committed to that.
These principles,
because it's very hard to be consistent
these days.
It is hard to because especially as you
know,
the,
some of the folks,
we conserve our allies,
but they,
they have their mind on Christianity
and,
and other stuff.
They changed their mind.
So the word committed here is I think is
the most important one.
Right.
So you're itching to get right into it.
Get into.
I want to get into a fight,
but get into flow all the way from New
York with.
Yeah.
Alright.
So we're gonna talk about our friend of
course.
Of course.
A Pfizer.
You've been on the show before.
I have,
yeah.
Thank you for inviting me again.
Yeah,
my pleasure.
So you guys work together and uh,
I want to do a little bit just on your
histories first.
So since we've had feisal here,
let's start with you Melissa.
So you are originally from Singapore.
I moved here,
but I moved here in 2004 for college.
Um,
worked and then went to Grad school and
continue working.
I love it.
And I,
you know,
I got sold the American dream and the
American ideals,
I think,
you know,
in part it's the same thing that drew
both of us here,
you know,
we,
we couldn't have more different
backgrounds.
Phase all grew up under a dictatorship
in Baghdad and he has only known war and
strife his whole life,
but I've had an interesting parallel
childhood it Singapore where it's a
benevolent dictatorship,
so,
you know,
he grew up under those circumstances,
but it was safe and,
and,
and very prosperous,
you know,
city and life there is stable.
Yeah.
So I think that people,
at least in America,
I'm trying to expand some,
some worldly knowledge on people,
but I feel like people don't really know
anything about Singapore.
So when you say a benevolent
dictatorship,
what,
what does that even mean?
Well,
it's been a single party state since
1965.
One government has one party has ruled
the country since,
since that time ever since it's gained
independence.
Um,
and,
and they are,
you know,
economic freedoms are,
are,
are extremely well developed in
Singapore,
I think Heritage Foundation listed as
two out of 180 on the economic freedom
index.
Right.
But if you look at political freedom,
you know,
freedom of expression,
freedom of the press,
it's virtually nonexistent.
So basically there's freedom to sort of
pursue the work that you want,
but not necessarily say the things that
you want.
It is a neo liberal contradiction in
that regard because it's extremely
fiscally austere,
low taxes,
free trade deregulation.
It's all the buzzwords that,
you know,
the right wing economists,
love right by it.
On the other hand,
um,
you know,
I,
I think it's sort of throwing a wrench
into Milton Friedman's capitalism and
freedom.
His theory about,
he said that economic freedom is a
necessary precondition to political
freedom and civil freedoms and that's
not really happening.
So that's really interesting.
So Singapore sorta got half of it,
right,
because the economic part,
but not the social part in the political
part right now.
Of course you come
from both of them are in my country.
We got everything.
So she's got one for two and you got a
little bit has to do with some of the
things that we did here in America.
So for the people that don't know your
story,
give me like a two minute recap of
growing up in Iraq and catches up on.
Well,
I mean,
I was born in Iraq and I was born in
Babylon and raised in Baghdad.
Uh,
my first year was under Saddam Hussein,
the dictatorship,
and then afterwards the US invasion of
Iraq happened and uh,
continuing with civil war,
I mean,
my spark for activism was kind of a
mixed of because after the intervention
we had the first rocket elections and I
saw the rise of secretary and politics
and I,
since I was a young boy back then I was
advocating for secular values and uh,
just to prevent the rise of terrorist
groups like what we have right now
because I was afraid that if I want to
grow up,
takes over the other and that's good.
Not obviously go.
And um,
I left.
So within,
like the Sol was rising,
I lost members of my lost.
My brother lost my cousin.
I was also a lot,
so friends and the had to leave Iraq in
2009.
Um,
and actually a year afterwards I started
like the pages total global secular
humanist movement that eventually became
one of the largest in the world.
I left Iraq,
I went into country close to Singapore
and Malaysia and I applied for asylum,
uh,
through the NHCR United Nations
Committee for Refugees and I got
accepted to come to America.
Yeah.
So that 13.
So that's why I wanted to have you both
on together because I think it's really
interesting people that come from
different places and as you say on the
show all the time,
the idea is we talk about here transcend
borders,
they transcend ethnicity and nationality
and all of those things.
So when you were there and when you were
growing up,
there was,
did you have a political awakening while
you were there?
Did you realize that you couldn't say
some of the things that you wanted to
say in kind of stuff?
Absolutely.
So,
um,
Singapore,
it late,
you know,
when you first entered,
when somebody learns that I am from this
country,
they will say one or two things.
The first one is I heard chewing gum is
banned.
I.
Whoa,
I heard you can't bring bubble gum into
true.
Yes,
it is true.
Every chewing gum it used to be that
they've relaxed it a little so,
so you can't purchase it now.
Um,
you can't purchase chewing gum there.
It and it's for very,
um,
kind of silly reasons.
Possibly back in the 19 eighties,
you know,
Singapore was,
was developing economically,
right.
But,
but you can develop really fast
economically,
but the people's mindsets and civility
and tragedy of the common sort of
mindset hasn't had not developed.
So they went litter,
you know,
you stick your chewing gum on the doors
of the trains and then it gets stuck.
And so the government was like,
we're not going to spend tax dollars
cleaning this up so you can't handle the
chewing gum.
We're going to take it away.
Wow.
So that talk about it and authority.
Autocratic.
Yes.
Really at a very micro level,
like how authoritarian the government.
Yeah.
And that's,
that's a good example.
The second one is,
you know,
if one of the,
the,
the sort of the best gifts you can get
in Singapore for like tourists to bring
home that,
that people usually get is a t shirt
that says Singapore is a fine city and
on it they're all the different fines
that you can get,
like you can not eat on the,
on the public,
the public train systems and it's just a
country with very strong rule of law and
all sorts of,
all sorts of rules that you can't do
this and you can't do that and
everything under the guise of
maintaining social harmony.
No,
I assume it's some level that probably
works right at some level.
The social,
Huh?
We have not had,
you know,
radicalization of our Sunni Muslim
population.
Not,
not as much as any other country
actually I would say.
And it's been largely,
you know,
you've had,
you have Christians,
Hindus,
Buddhists,
Muslims,
living very harmoniously together.
We've not had any incidents.
So there is something to be said about,
about the methods of top down,
institutionalization of social harmony.
The problem is that manifests itself in
sedition laws,
blasphemy laws,
and as recently as last year,
it was used to throw a 17 year old
blogger into jail for wounding the the
feelings of religious people.
All he did was a say some stuff about
Jesus Christ and twink,
at least 20 grown up adults in Singapore
felt offended enough to file a police
report and they threw a 17 year old and
to Dale.
Right?
So we've talked a little bit about what
they've done to bloggers in Bangladesh
and Singapore and you've connected me
with the Bangladeshi blogger who I'm
going to have on soon.
These are the people that we need to be
caring about more,
right?
Because these are the people that you
guys could have been had you not left.
Yeah,
I mean they.
I mean everyone knows like whatever one
of these,
one of these folks get killed or like
what happened in Bangladesh
or do I be a good job?
We know that these guys are the
solution.
We know that they stand for the same
values.
What we stand for,
and we know the data,
the best counter they created.
The best counter narrative to extremist
I the,
like the Sam Harris of Saudi Arabia.
Yes.
He's an intellectual who has advocated
for great values that in a country that
is as extreme as Saudi Arabia,
they wouldn't have changed the world in
Saudi Arabia.
That is one of the main exporter of
Wahhabi ideology that killed the
bungalow bloggers that,
that created the Taliban,
which a country that has nuclear
weapons.
Um,
so yeah,
I mean we have to,
they are our best resource that we
should always continue to help them as
much as we can and whenever we can.
Yeah.
So when you were there and you saw this
sort of authoritarianism,
when did you realize,
all right,
if I'm gonna Express what's in me,
I may have to leave.
I started realized that in high school,
um,
in,
in Singapore,
many,
many of the best schools,
like at the top,
you know,
in academia,
um,
they were religious schools,
you know,
it's just like a sort of a stage of the
colonial era.
When the British came,
it was a British colony and,
and you had all the missionaries from
France,
from,
from Europe.
They came to set up schools to educate
the locals.
And so this became associated with a
economics like high academic standards.
So I ended up going to,
you know,
a methodist schools which were
associated with a very high academic
standards.
Right.
Did you grow up methodist?
Yes.
And I did.
So,
so the religious,
the religious schools,
where are quite a force to reckon with
in Singapore and in producing graduates.
And I guess I realized that,
I mean this is a country that is very
self enforcing in terms of political
correctness.
If you can't,
you know,
there's all sorts of rules and you,
the reason people don't,
don't do something or don't litter is
because there's,
there's a fine waiting to happen.
So,
so the motivation to,
to do something or to not do something
is completely extrinsic.
So we're all self policing each other.
And I,
I sort of,
you know,
bought into the,
the,
uh,
sort of ideal of the United States,
the first amendment,
the freedom of expression,
freedom of speech because I was always
that rebellious,
you know,
skeptic in my circle,
in my religious circle and,
and school,
which is pretty much overlapped at that
point.
Um,
and that's when I realized I need to get
out.
You really need to get out if I,
if I need it to,
if I want it to broaden my mind and
fulfill that.
Yeah.
I'm curious when you hear the phrase
self policing in a place like Singapore
and their self policing because of fines
and sort of this authoritarian thing.
So one of the things I've been saying on
the short time is that we now self
policing
ourselves in America.
So it's not coming.
You know,
we always used to fear the idea that the
government is what's going to come in
and take away our Frisco.
But now it's we're doing it to ourselves
and what's happening in academia,
which I want to talk to you guys a
little bit,
but when you hear that,
does that make you crazy knowings from
where you came?
Exactly.
Nineteen 84,
but four people,
right?
It's backwards.
It's something like 1984.
Yeah.
I mean,
to be honest,
I,
when I,
before I came to United States,
I had like a very good image of what,
like when I came to America,
the people,
especially the people who believe in St
Louis with as I am the secular liberals
of the,
of the West with just give and I will
say at first because the movement has
changed.
Write something on the left has changed
over the last couple of years.
So when you moved here,
I'm guessing maybe it was a little more
welcoming.
I mean it was,
I mean it was welcoming,
but I thought it would be more
welcoming.
I didn't know that there was this huge
splits.
The fact that if I can,
if anybody can be advocating for same
sex marriage in a,
in a western country,
it's totally okay.
But the moment you talk about it in a
Muslim country,
it becomes,
yeah,
yeah.
And I didn't know about these dynamics
that when you talk about the same values
that the American liberals that have
cared for when you move it to a
universal or another country,
you would immediately be called a
racist.
And so when I got into that,
I started getting attacked left or
right,
or like,
oh,
what I'm saying is that I support same
sex marriage.
And they like,
oh well that is a form of colonialism.
And I'm like,
no fucking getting made because you're
saying the same thing for like the
United States.
And I just said that I believe that gays
are humans.
Even in Iraq,
like I,
I think they are humans.
They breathe and they have the same DNA
for human beings are really out there
stuff.
So,
so like I don't really think of myself
as a radical person.
Like I think that I'm advocating as.
But the moment you just shifted to a
different culture,
quote unquote,
because what I found very difficult here
is that because we are minorities coming
from,
um,
the majority dominate here,
so I'm a minority all the time.
But when it comes to color of my skin,
I'm the majority.
So here in America,
there is this concept of the authentic
voice when it comes to minorities,
is that there are these stereotypes,
whether it's from the right on the left,
like if you are from this specific race,
these,
the issues that you should care about
the most in this specific order.
If you are a Mexican,
you should care about immigration and,
and so on.
And if you,
if you are Arab,
they expect this image about,
okay,
he's an,
he's a young man,
so he must hate the west.
He must be very angry against the United
States about what Bush did to Iraq.
And they must hate capitalism and he
must all this stuff.
So if you don't fit into that narrative,
you're immediately going to be attacked
as some sort of like uncle Tom or which
is itself racist without them noticing
it.
Right?
That's what I keep saying.
They're actually using real racism
because they're not judging you by
what's in your mind.
They're judging you by what they think
of King is like rolling as a grave right
now because it's like the.
So,
so that's actually one of the most
difficult things I found over here is
that how come you don't subscribe to my
order date?
My notions of who you should be.
Like I'm like I'm individually as you
are and,
and,
and now like we can see it in the US
elections in which I've seen many people
on both sides I would say especially I
would say on the far left who are like,
how can you as a,
as a black,
not support Bernie or something like
that.
While black people have,
they have,
they have agency and they may rush
rationally think of supporting one
person over the other.
Like you can disagree with them,
but that's completely fine.
But to say like,
why is he as a black person,
you don't say that about a white person,
they'll say like maybe support trump,
but like coming again from white people
on the left see a critical race theory
from like White Guilt University of
California and they are suddenly now
experts of race relations and what the
dynamics of the Middle East are.
Right?
And they project themselves as being the
intellectuals.
So that's really interesting.
And because we talked so much about the
Middle East and we talk about extremism
and Islam and whatever,
I see a very specific reason why you get
something like that.
I'm curious,
having left Singapore,
having,
you know,
believing in secular values and atheism
and all that,
do you find some of that,
that soft bigotry of low expectations
that we talk about?
No,
I don't.
In fact I'm probably a beneficiary of
have high expectations,
right?
I mean,
so anyway,
that joke that Chris Rock made at the
Oscars with the little kids.
Yeah,
with the little accountants and,
and you know,
for some reason the,
the,
the Asian community was really up in
arms about that stereotype.
Even though it's a positive three
positive stereotypes.
So w,
what did you feel when you heard that?
That's good.
Okay.
So I did get into some online fights
about this because again,
his face all says because of your race,
you know,
like seemingly Asian person,
you should be finding this thing
offensive.
You shouldn't laugh at it.
You should,
you know,
a sale and rally against an end sort of,
um,
deny as stereotypes.
Forgetting that this is in the context
of humor.
Um,
and,
and the same thing with what Sarah,
Sacha Baron Cohen said about the little
minions,
like,
that really blew,
like even Jeremy Lin,
the basketballs got into that and I
think it's just,
you know,
I,
I was asking people rhetorically like
what,
what happens to comedy if,
if you just take all stereotypes out of
it,
you have to be angry at South Park.
You have to be angry at snl.
Everybody.
I mean,
this whole season,
did you guys watch South Park this
season?
I mean,
this whole season,
I think it might've been the best season
ever.
Literally
the entire season was dedicated.
Watch it.
Well,
there you go.
So the whole season was dedicated to
fighting these exact ideas.
Right,
exactly.
And,
and the thing about taking a fence is,
you know,
I always ask people like,
who creates the offense,
the offense,
the person who offended by the person
who feels the offense,
who is the one that actually created it
because it doesn't happen in a vacuum.
Right?
So there's a particularly interesting
notion with what you're saying because
the stereotypes.
So when Chris rock brought out the
three,
or was it three?
Yeah,
three.
One of them was actually had a Jewish
name,
so.
Right.
So the Jewish people weren't angry,
so just for people that didn't see it.
So they brought out three Asian kids.
One of them had a Jewish name and they
were supposed to all be like accountant
from price waterhouse.
So they're all supposed to be really
bright accounts,
blah blah.
But so the stereotype that they're using
is a positive stereotype.
The implication is,
oh,
these are educated kids that are going
to go on and be good at math and they
excel academically.
Right.
So when,
when people were upset with you or when
you said I'm okay with the humor in that
the people that were upset,
what were,
what were they saying?
Like did they feel that that's causing
some sort of backlash?
Yeah,
so the,
they don't like the perpetuating of the
model minority and they think that that
sets up a standard where now every agent
has to live up to that.
I think they're reading too much into
it.
You know,
it's,
it's just a reflection of,
of stereotypes that have a grain of
truth in the case of have a leg who made
that joke about.
He said,
well,
you know,
this,
this Oscar's is all about diversity,
but what about them?
Little yellow guys,
you know,
who,
who have the little dogs?
And then he paused.
Everybody laughed,
right?
So everybody assumed that he was talking
about Asians and then he said,
oh,
you know the minions.
So the job was actually on you because
you are the ones who did the stereotype
thing.
And,
and I don't think people,
they just reacted to that.
They will like,
oh,
leg saying,
you know that Asians have small,
small dogs,
and I was just like,
well actually this is the anatomy of
humor and if you don't know Ali g as a
character and,
and,
and how he's playing off his humor,
he's actually saying you're the one who
stereotyping.
So just to be clear,
he did something really clever there
because he took you one way or made you
laugh and then immediately takes you the
other place.
So you're right,
it's on you,
on you.
You're the one who stereotyped left and
you thought that he meant Asian people.
So
I think all of this is directly linked
to the authoritarianism stuff,
right?
So you came from an authoritarian
government.
You were not allowed to say,
you know,
I'm a,
I'm a free thinker in a secularist.
You've,
you've laid out why you can't,
you know,
lived under an authoritarian rule and
now we see this happening here and I'm
firmly,
I firmly believe that we are in like
some really murky waters in America
right now and in the West in general.
So what do we do to fight this?
Well,
I mean there a,
I think I do my step because now it is,
is coming to our lines here and it's
happening over there
and um,
when it comes to what's happening over
there,
I mean,
I think the best solution for is to
support the values that I think to be on
the right side of history on this battle
between authoritarianism and I would
include a theocratic fascism in the end,
the umbrella and uh,
and the values of John Stuart Mill and
Jefferson and,
uh,
the values of,
of the free man.
And you think,
do you guys think that those are values
are the left anywhere?
When you think of John Stuart Mill or
classic liberalism?
It seems to me that that's not even a
value.
That really.
Yeah,
I mean the last has shifted and the
right has shifted.
Like now we live in a moment.
You can look at the elections,
then you can see for yourself like we
live in a very polarized.
I mean there's,
there's no discussion about everything.
Like you can start by whether it's Islam
or abortion or gun control or a glass of
water.
And one of the things like,
well the things that I like because like
it's like a,
it's a dogma and like you can actually
know someone,
someone position from abortion about
abortion and gun control,
but ask them questions,
right?
Or don't like what do you think about
abortion?
And then you can actually know that a
position on gun control,
because it's like now is like this
polarization of like dogmatism of the 10
commandments of the left,
the 10 commandments of the riots.
And so I think that both sides have kind
of lost principles.
I've even the quote unquote the right.
I mean they are supposedly about the
free market,
but they want to police people's,
a vagina and a job.
They are not as,
they're not as a free,
uh,
they as they claim to be.
I mean they want to police marriage and
marriage equality.
They want to police a woman's
reproductive rights and the stuff and
the left one.
Supposedly they'll.
The guys are free speech one to how the
police.
The sad part here,
if we're jumping onto the political side
of this,
that the one guy who wanted smaller
government,
the one guy who wanted rand Paul who
wanted,
who's as close to a libertarian that
we're going to get into the mainstream
parties and I had Gary Johnson on here a
couple weeks ago who's running under the
libertarian ticket.
Unfortunately.
Good luck.
Good luck for that.
Unfortunately,
we still don't have a legitimate,
truly legitimate third party yet,
but I think that after the craziness of
this year,
I actually think it's possible for 20
slash 20,
but is that the real fault?
So we focus on the left,
but there was a moment that they're
right.
Could have said,
all right,
maybe this is the guy that we should
listen to because he's got some of our
principals and then they kicked him out
after one bad caucus.
I think it was actually Islamic
extremism.
What was going on in the Middle East
that really did rand Paul's campaign in
the rise of Isis and,
and you know,
the,
the havoc that was racking the refugees.
It's sort of,
it's sort of implicated that the United
States couldn't be isolationists and the
libertarian position is to just,
you know,
hold back.
So I think that's what kind of killed.
I'm rand Paul's Rand Paul said.
Yeah.
It was interesting because when I had
Gary Johnson on,
I didn't know what his policy was on
because
of the libertarian really you can,
you don't have to be so like just like
this and so ron everything.
So when I asked him about some Middle
East stuff and some foreign policy
stuff,
he actually did feel that there is still
a role for the United States.
Didn't really lay out exactly what it
was really interesting.
I mean with the Libertarian Party as
well,
as I mentioned,
there's this concept of isolationism
which are very strong in the.
But I thing is like if you're not
interested in the Middle East and Middle
East is interested in us,
but what happens in the Middle East
doesn't.
It's not Las Vegas.
Like what happens in Iraq doesn't stay
in,
even though we have the same mother
between Vegas and Iraq,
but one thing that does,
that's,
that doesn't stay over there.
And uh,
and that's one thing is Islamic
extremism and I mean because one of the
good things about Islam and I always
admitted like it is the least price
that's religion and it is very universal
and it always talks about universal
values.
I mean one of the famous quotes of
Prophet Mohammad in which he said,
but there's no difference between Arab
and non Arab except by I'm like,
I think how much faithful he is.
So,
so that,
so the,
well that's universal.
Except he was saying you have to
convert.
Yes.
Religion transcend borders is that you
can be a,
like the values of Islam can't transcend
borders.
Not like a tribal religion.
Let's say like Judaism is with,
with Islam.
So what effects what's happening in the
Middle East can effect like many people
who are recruiters for Isis are in the
Middle East,
but the recruiting on the Internet for
people living in the West.
But I'm failing to see how you see this
as a positive thing because it isn't
that showing why it's spreading.
No,
I mean a.
it's a double edged sword is that it's a
good thing that is not racist,
but it's a bad thing that is universal,
right?
To do that as a little more bad.
But back to the isolation.
The isolation is believed that if we can
just secure the borders,
if you can ban everybody from entering
or whatever.
Even the Libertarians are clinical
educator because they believe in open
borders as the same time reducing the
welfare state.
So in that way we can accept more
immigrants.
So yeah.
How are we going to deal with that?
Like with Islamic extremism rising gap
with the refugees coming in with people
from the West getting recruited to join
terrorist groups that may actually make
attacks here in the west,
like Paris attacks and Charlie Hebdo and
even like now some like my friend just
recently came from Germany.
She's a woman from Afghanistan and she
said like in,
in some hotels telling data are telling
women not to go out at night out of fear
of being harassed by the newcomers and
which then ultimately just strengthens
the far right.
Exactly.
Tweeted this morning,
I saw,
I saw an article in Germany that at one
of the public pools were allowed lot.
The migrants are going to.
That there were,
there were a lot of men that were
attacking women and children,
so now they're.
Their resolution is that they're going
to segregate by sex,
so you know,
weird way now the government came in and
the most sort of the thing that religion
would want the most.
Now we're going to separate men and
women and guess what?
When people aren't having sex as Bill
Maher would say that sort of fertile
ground for extremists or extremism.
I think the horseshoe theory is like one
of the best way to play and sex is like
not.
Not also.
They also theater is like how much they
feed into each other is that the more
people say that there is no problem with
Islam,
the more people on the far right will be
getting more powerful because whenever,
because there's a correlation between
the rise of terrorist attacks and the
rise of far right groups,
another sunrise grows,
but the need for them to get mobilized
and like people like trump or people
like the edl and defense league or a
material upon the fronds that when the
Paris attacks happened,
that moment is like,
let's get mobilized.
Let's,
let's,
uh,
we're losing our way of life and,
and stuff.
So I mean this is one of the biggest
issues,
and we were talking about it a few days
ago,
is that with the rise of the far right,
when they start quote unquote killing
Muslims,
I'd want attack Muslims and all of that.
They're not all that.
They're attacking people who look Muslim
as well there.
I mean,
I,
I don't have no one's Hashtag on my face
saying I'm a Muslim,
but even I'm not going to advocate for
attacking Muslims either.
I mean,
my parents are Muslims,
but I grew up with Muslims,
I love many of them,
but I don't want.
So what's happening is that when people
do not acknowledge the problem there is
these guys are going to be and they're
going to be attacking six and they're
going to be attacking anybody who looks
Brown.
Right?
So that's the problem is that there
absolutely are true racist,
right?
There absolutely are true bigots.
And by the way,
that's why I had Tommy Robinson on my
show.
I don't agree with everything he says
and I don't fully understand everything
about what's going on in,
in the UK and Europe,
but I'm trying to learn and I know he
had tried to,
at least from what I understand,
separated himself from some of the more
racist elements of the EDL and some of
those organizations.
So I thought it was worthy of a
conversation.
But I think this is a good segue to
something you said earlier.
So a certain in Singapore,
a certain amount of authoritarianism.
It sounds like it made people coexist
and is that sort of on the surface?
So is that sort of a,
it's a very,
like you got to thread that needle
really carefully,
right?
Yeah.
Um,
you know,
it,
it ultimately,
it's,
it's a political philosophy question.
And also what is the purpose of
government,
right?
Is it,
is it to maintain the most stable
society?
Is it to raise the standard of living of
most people?
And do the ends ultimately justify the
means because to get there,
you know,
their,
for example,
like we in 2007 we've had,
have you make racist comments on your
blog,
you can be jailed.
Um,
so you're not free to,
to,
to make these comments and how,
how else does that manifest?
Right?
So in the United States,
anybody can say any racist thing they
want,
um,
you'll never be thrown into jail for
that anyway.
You might be booted off twitter,
but also,
I mean the word racist,
I mean,
it could be perceived as racist,
can get you in jail.
There's a subtly,
what we probably all know what racism
is.
It could be something that they say
like,
oh,
because people could be something that,
no,
absolutely it's a good racism for me,
but the sedition and blasphemy laws
essentially protect also the criticism
of religion,
religious institutions from often very
necessary criticism,
right?
It's like I can't even go there.
You can't critique and,
and it,
it creates that climate where where
people just don't question because
they're afraid and they don't talk
about.
They just,
they're a decent safe spaces right now.
Let's not go talking about.
I'm talking about religion.
We can't,
we can discuss racism very well in
Singapore.
It's a very sensitive.
Let's not talk about it.
So people tread on eggshells and,
and I mean it's funny because I feel
like I sort of escaped that.
That scenario,
like the right sort of top down,
government instituted curtailing of the
freedom of speech come to theu ,
s and slowly on campuses.
What starts happening is now the left
asking for the same thing the students
are asking for safe spaces.
What you said about the segregation in
Germany,
right?
Essentially that's what religion is
doing is creating a safe space between
men and women.
Yeah.
So like what phase also at the horseshoe
theory does come together,
you know,
let the left and the right extreme left
the effectively are kind of achieving
the same result.
But also like worth mentioning about
like Singapore even like I can't believe
I'm actually from Asia.
I'm actually on the same continent and
Asia and I'll try to keep that in mind.
I'm judging you for now is that within a
eastern cultures there is a lot of sense
of collectivism and the and the concepts
of tribalism that makes it easier for
leaders to tell them like the philosophy
of Buddhism and Confucianism that
there's others respect to the leader and
like,
so like I said,
it's generally like a culture of self in
China is like a.
so,
so what's happening is that is open to
people like when they talk about change
in the Middle East and things of that
sort and Jolene,
eastern culture,
you will see that you don't need to
create a critical mass because you don't
need to check most of individuals
because it's a collective culture.
If you change the leader and the leader
telling people to look at Iraq for
example,
within,
if you look at the history of rock the
last 50 years,
you'll see 50 years ago women were free
and some places are in Europe,
you know,
and the moment that the leadership
change,
they killed some civil society activists
and stuff.
The moment everybody start worshiping
and then,
and,
and so on.
So did you see,
uh,
I'm trying to interrupt,
but did you see this meme about a,
there was about 30 women from different
countries,
you saw this,
30 women are 50 women,
may be from different countries at
mostly Arab countries or at least Muslim
majority countries showing what their,
what their actual dress,
the indigenous dress that is supposed to
be in.
It's all vibrant and they are free in
their clothes and it says it's not
supposed to be this.
And then they show with one of the
things that like what ideology of
[inaudible] and our hub is in what's
called used to call himself.
I'm not the web,
it's called himself a Muslim reformer
that he wanted to make all the Muslim
world homogeneous and that's part of
some of his success because they're
appealing to this concept that Oh,
we all have different than humans and a
different cultures and stuff,
but yet all my bringing all of you under
one caliphate all under one ideology and
all of them I need to order the same
address and all.
Many.
And it's appealing to some people and
not appealing to those who are cultured,
but that's another reason it has been to
some extent successful because it
appeals to the people who want to have
the collective mindset to want to be
like part of one umbrella and one
leadership.
And that's what an Arabic is called
Omar,
the Islamic Omar,
the Arabic Omar come from,
is that this concept of one leadership
in one community and,
and all of that.
So the three of us sitting here,
three secular people,
atheist,
right.
So you grew up methodist.
I didn't even know that until we sat
down just now.
You grew up Muslim,
right?
That's to some extent to where my
parents are liberal,
but yeah.
But I grew up in a Muslim culture.
Certainly in a Muslim culture.
I grew up Jewish.
I still consider myself Jewish,
but I'm not a believer in,
in a,
in a magical.
You don't believe in a talking donkey.
I don't believe in the talking donkey or
the fire.
They talked to her,
all that stuff and the way,
you know,
um,
but it's ideas that brought us all here.
And that's why I wanted to have youtube
on together because I think that that's
really interesting.
It shows that these concepts are
irrelevant,
you know,
these concepts,
transcend borders and all of that stuff.
I really like what really interested me
about sort of joining forces with
Faisal,
especially right now with the shift
that,
that he's doing with a human rights.
He's focusing not just on the atheist
movement or the secular movement.
Well,
what can we do about it?
So he's now working in human rights and,
and the reason I'm so supportive of that
and want to be involved in that is
because for me,
you know,
I grew up in a country where I think one
of the,
the,
the founding father of Singapore,
Mr Lee Kuan Yew,
who,
who recently passed away,
one of the most dangerous legacies,
he's probably one of the greatest
statesmen modern statesman,
you know,
um,
ever.
And he's built a country that went from
third world to first world in just three
decades.
It's a feat that,
I mean,
it's,
it's amazing what he's done for the
country,
but I'm,
on the other hand,
he sort of legitimize this term which
kind of bothers me is he says that it's
called Asian values that because Asia,
because of his history and culture,
um,
the western ideas of,
of,
you know,
liberal democracy cannot apply and it
doesn't fit well within the culture and
he uses confucianism as a bulwark
against that,
like what he was saying about
collectivism and,
and so it sort of pits,
you know,
the West Western ideas and it says,
oh,
it's invalid here.
It can work here.
And to me that is cultural relativism.
You know,
it,
it violates human rights.
Like it's not,
it's not consistent with this saying he
saying sort of be free but not that free
because that's sort of what will
undermine what we've built.
Well they are re,
they legitimize their able to legitimize
repressive policies under the guise of
Asian values.
It's almost like exceptionalism.
Like you know,
we prioritize social harmony and
prosperity over individual freedom and
this is our culture.
So,
so our policies fit that.
And I think for me that was what was
very dangerous about that idea and you
start seeing it being replicated in
Russia,
like Putin's doing that.
Um,
I see Jinping and China and they're
taking the leaf out of his book now and
creating almost like parallel
alternative to western democracy.
And part of that,
again,
it
goes to the way we see Europe having so
many problems right now and we don't see
those problems in Russia.
Right?
I mean certainly the immigration stuff,
we don't see that in Russia.
And because of that then it makes
probably the average European,
it makes poodle look kind of good even
if they don't like.
But also it's worth mentioning that
Russia is not a country worth
immigrating to.
So they want somebody who's a refugee
himself.
He wanted to go somewhere warm,
totally warm.
But I want to have a country that is
probably different than where I come
from.
It does.
But authoritarianism is that I'm in
Europe.
I mean obviously it's much better
economically and much better socially
that makes less people.
But,
but yeah,
I mean when you have an open border
policy that's,
I think Germany would probably have it
and the net not a very strong vetting
system you're going to have because as I
said,
there was the rise of far right and
Islamic terrorist attacks and if we are
not going to support the reformers and
the liberals are trying to change the
things in the societies because I mean
I,
I wrote an article about the Syrian
refugee crisis and one of the main
issues is that there is no solution to
Syrian refugees going to keep coming.
Yeah.
So if you're not going to find the
solution over there,
then it's,
this issue is going to continue all the
time.
So not always serious and as obviously
it's Libya has also having a problem at
the opiate and all the other countries
in the region and obviously Iraq since a
long time.
But the,
we're not going to find solutions over
there.
So other than just like a focus on
domestic issues.
That's where like libertarianism fails
because it's always deals with the
refugees are coming in.
But how can we reduce the amount of
refugees that are coming in for that
region that's by not subtly motor
intervention,
but at least being on the right side of
history and being with the people who
support the values that reduce the
amount of revenue.
Right.
I suspect that most libertarians would
say somebody like Rand Paul would say,
well,
I wasn't for the Iraq war,
so I didn't add to the chaos.
Right.
It's irrelevant now because here we are
now.
But that is not enough.
I mean,
this concept of like,
well,
but I'm not a racist is not enough to
two different things.
Yeah.
And,
and,
and I mean people talk about the numbers
and stuff.
I met Saddam Hussein killed hundreds of
thousands of people.
If they did not intervene,
there will also be hundreds of thousands
of people killed.
So,
so just because saying,
oh,
I'm against the war,
doesn't somebody make him a good person?
You know what I mean?
I mean,
I'm talking about practical solutions
for.
I mean,
the war happened and we have to deal
with it.
Yeah.
So that's a great segway to sort of what
you guys do because you know,
what you do with movements and what you
guys are doing together.
We have to empower these voices.
Um,
so just a few weeks ago I had someone on
the show from Iraq or I,
well,
I guess we can give her first name,
at least for now.
So we had moved on the show and she's a
secularist and atheist.
All the things that we all stand up for
her,
she's a minority within a minority.
Um,
I,
we can't get into the major details of
what's going on with her right now.
But suffice to say that you're helping
facilitate some of this stuff,
but these people are completely ignored.
Exactly.
And they're ignored by the people that
should care about them the most.
Exactly.
And,
and,
and the fact that this has no,
I mean it's been what,
15 years since nine slash 11 happened
and it's been the same mentor over and
over again that there's no policy change
of who exactly the people we should
start with.
And we have a country like Saudi Arabia
as our ally and we have Qatar that I
recently discovered funds the Muslim
Brotherhood,
which is using slave labor by the way,
to build a cub stadium to actually like
I want to raise this point,
which I think is very important.
I the Muslim Brotherhood is actually
much more dangerous than the ideology of
Islam is because they are able to work
on the grassroots level and also they
have double faces.
And what's happening is that they want
to say hopefully traded the US
government because at that may say made
me sound like a fucking lunatic.
But they have a lot of people say it
though,
but there have been places in in think
tanks and all the shows everywhere that
told,
told the Western world that they,
that these other guys,
the secretaries and stuff are traitors
and they're not the good guys and we
should help us.
So that kind of have a block for,
for a large.
For Charles like Al Jazeera and they
have kind of block this concept of
secular Arab.
It was like they wanted to push this
image of the authentic Arab of the
person who,
so this is,
we are Islamists and we'll have to
settle with it while in fact,
my policy and I want to change is that
we should change what we need to settle
what we are asking us to subtle when I
should not settle with Islamic jihadist.
We have to support those who agree with
our values.
Yeah.
Does all of that ring as true to you as
it does to me in terms of that we're
skipping a step here.
We're,
we're skipping caring about the right
people because of all,
for all the wrong reasons,
right?
Yeah,
absolutely.
Um,
I,
I think it's,
it's sort of extremely symptomatic of,
um,
sort of criticism now that that's
happening in,
in the left.
And,
uh,
I,
you know,
the,
the problem with that also is,
is that it's created like a vacuum
where,
where you have like people like trump
who was coming in and inciting inciting
so much hate against these people and
blanketing,
blanketing all Muslims and,
and that's just feeding,
that's just feeding the ends up eating
the problem.
Right.
And you come from the academic world.
I mean,
as I mentioned at the top of the show,
you got your phd at Mit.
Oh,
you're on your way to your phd at Mit in
genetics,
right?
So you,
you know,
your stuff,
you're in the academic world.
Do you see this?
I think one of the people,
one of the things people struggle with,
is this coming more from the students or
the academics or is it,
is it both?
It's
more coming from the students for sure.
Uh,
I would say that I'm on campus at Mit.
We haven't had that much incidents,
but over over the,
you know,
the t stuff at Harvard,
um,
we had had way more,
way more incidents like recently the
last,
the law school had to change.
I think they're wanting to change their,
their,
their crest because it features three
bushels of wheat.
Um,
and,
and they're also like house masters now
I'm at the dorms.
They,
they've lost their titles,
they're called Dean faculty assistance
or something.
So,
you know,
the question becomes what happens to
your master's degree or like master of
the universe,
like,
you know,
just words like that,
I,
I posted something recently about like
in chemistry,
they,
you know,
the,
one of the greatest achievements in the
last couple of months was that they
actually created a new synthetic element
that stable.
So we add it.
We completed the seventh row of the
periodic table.
And,
and in the article they called it a
manmade elements,
right?
And they had to change.
So they had to change the word manmade
because people took a lot of offense at
the word.
They said,
Oh,
you know,
this is,
uh,
it's,
it's excluding women.
It implies,
you know,
implies that it's the Patriarchy who's
involved in this.
But,
you know,
in Latin,
the word madness,
his hand and man mean it doesn't really
come from man.
Oh.
So the entomology entomology is,
you know,
I mean people take offense firsts and,
and that's the first reaction.
So I was telling face all of this many
times.
The problem with what's happening,
you know,
in,
in the regressive left movement is,
is,
uh,
this desire to see the worst in
everybody.
For example,
Matt Taylor,
the Rosetta Scientists,
right?
Who landed up the comment,
uh,
the probe on a comment,
um,
he wore a shirt,
you know,
inappropriate for an interview.
But the first instinct is to assume,
can you tell people what the shirt was?
Just this shirt had,
um,
it was like a tessellation of like pin
up girls with guns or something.
It was a cartoon.
It was,
it was actually a gift from a female
artist friend.
It was just a silly,
silly shirt.
It wasn't very graphic at all.
It was,
it's,
you know,
I mean,
I wouldn't wear it.
But,
um,
uh,
and,
and he wore that,
you know,
announcing the,
um,
the triumphant achievement of his team
and,
and immediately just the,
the outcry online forced him into tears
when he had to apologize.
And,
and I don't know how you make the leap
from guy wearing shirt to just infer.
I mean like if I feel like a big part of
this is wanting to see this rate,
this racist,
sexist,
whatever it is,
intent,
the moment you catch something that may
be,
you know,
can be interpreted that way.
They interpret it in the most extreme
way.
And then the reaction starts there.
And then the whole outrage,
I'm industrial complex begins online.
Um,
and then,
and then after that,
it's a cycle,
right?
Like there's that little thing,
you find it and then blow up and then
the people will criticize the blow,
the people who are bitching about the
bitching and then,
you know,
it's just a cycle.
Yeah.
So what do you guys make of that mind
reading portion of this?
Because psychoanalysis,
phds are being thrown around everywhere.
Well,
because when I,
the first episode of the show is you
guys know what I had Sam Harris and he
said something about the mind reading.
They want to just find something in you,
which is exactly what you just said.
And once they can find the green of
something,
now they can extrapolate it into every
which way that they want to judge you,
which you sold the reverse,
I think of how rational people actually
operate and how evidence based people
and people of science
that can also just compassion that that
is supposedly part of liberalism,
right?
It should be one of the things that we
aspire to is to actually see the best in
people.
I don't know,
but that's just me.
Yeah.
I mean I don't think it's just one of
the things that make me sad because like
this outrage requires energy,
right?
So I wish that some of.
I mean I'm not trying to trivialize that
experience or whatever they may think of
me,
but I wish some of that outrage and all
these hashtags would be used to advocate
for people like Lupe.
Now for people like Ryan,
for people who are like,
I wish that energy of so much out of.
I mean if they get offended by a
Halloween costume,
I wish they got offended by a woman
getting acid thrown in their faces by
the Taliban in Pakistan.
I was offended by bloggers getting
beheaded and in Bangladesh like I wish
that some of that energy and not like
tell them not to talk about this stuff,
but I wish some of that energy at least
like maybe just 10 percent.
I'm not really asking for much like I
like 10 percent is pretty good.
This is lower than the taxes of trump
and 10 percent if they just use some of
that outreach,
some of that energy and it creates a
movement at least of solidarity.
I don't want them to donate a million
dollar or billion dollar.
Just a moment of solidarity.
They show that we people in a free
societies side with the values you side
with and that.
I mean for me when I was living there,
that's meant a lot to me and when people
told me that I want to replicate that to
help the folks over there who did that
sense of solidarity.
And again it doesn't.
It show rick and tee shirt doesn't
achieve a certain level of narcissism
to.
Because it seems to me that when they do
this they're just saying why can't blame
everything on myself?
And now that's a problem they want,
you know what I mean?
If they can't link America,
there's something,
it's not even a problem.
So that also seems to be a bit of the.
And that is,
I mean look at like many of the
definition of racism is power plus
privilege,
right?
Is it getting it right?
Prevalent?
They,
they because they look.
So for example,
racism,
they redefined racism.
So racism is no longer about people
hating of people of other races,
but rather it is who are the people on
the privileged side.
So.
So it has to be.
So at the top of the pyramid we talked
about last time,
there is a cisgender white male.
He's worse than Isis.
And so then there's probably isis
because they're brown.
Mel's probably the,
the social media guys are mostly white
but,
but uh,
but the other side is like a pyramid and
the top of the pyramid is white smell
and they think he is the biggest
problem.
So ironically what they're saying
actually is that you as an Arab,
as Arab landscape man,
you could not be racist against me or
against me.
But I know that someone of that,
an Asian person is probably lined up,
it's very sort of right next to white
privilege so that you,
even if you were endorsing white
genocide,
wouldn't be viewed as racist because you
were being oppressed and that has been
actually like there was this case,
I think it was in Goldsmith University
in which one of the students was talking
about a genocide,
this stock white genocide.
And then she said,
this is my way to surprise my
grievances.
Yeah.
Because there's no other way to get more
creative then.
And then she said this is,
this is not actually racist.
What I was talking about because I am a
from,
except the fact that she lives in
London,
she's under privileged and she's trying
to suppress our grievances against the
people from the upper class.
This last night in the debate,
didn't Bernie say something about how
white people don't know what it's like
to be poor?
I mean,
something of that effect.
I did not watch the debate because I was
out.
But uh,
I saw this coach has been circled.
Yeah.
And because they,
they,
they will say,
well mean some of the concept,
I mean I,
I'm,
I agree with some of the,
with it's called intersectionality.
I mean it may accept the fact that many
people who say it are crazy nut jobs
because it has a good concept is that
the people who are,
for example,
block have less likely to get jobs
because of their names.
So,
so it is difficult if you are a block to
raise to middle class then if you're
otherwise tries to America.
So there is some truth to this.
But what is happening is that it is
mixed up with so much baggage of
bullshit that doesn't make sense
anymore.
Just like when the,
when the far right talk about we should
be fearful of all of these things.
Things except the fact that some of
infiltration of the Muslim Brotherhood,
all these things like because there are
so insane about so many other things
that like whenever there's a shooting,
Obama's trying to take our guns,
you don't take them anywhere.
So whatever they say.
So what's happening with
intersectionality and the people on the
far left.
Some of what they say is through third
is that there are people who are,
because of the rights of men,
there are studies done even based upon
the name,
like if people who have like different
names,
if they sound for it and whatever,
they are less likely to get employment.
So yes,
there is a sense of when somebody is
tired to bullshit us,
so then they extrapolated into gaze for
Hammas and then.
Yeah.
Which is valuing.
So,
so that is what that is where like the,
like a huge bag of bullshit is that when
all of these like intersectionality and
critical race theory,
critical old,
literally start defending people that
would have,
you can because under the name they are
a minority and all of this eventually
gets like,
it's like the destructive when it's all
this stuff mixed together.
So as three people here sitting here,
that all came at different points in our
lives.
So I'm a,
I'm a third generation American.
Uh,
you guys are first generation but
different skin colors and that,
all of that stuff,
we're putting it out there.
We're not fooling anybody.
Uh,
you sort of touched on this earlier,
but American exceptionalism,
do you believe in American
exceptionalism?
Because I get all right.
I do,
I do too.
But
tell me why I like this quote by Bill
Clinton and he said whatever is wrong in
America can,
can be fixed by what's rights in America
and as a stance now before the
elections,
I can say that with a straight face.
Yeah.
I mean,
I'm,
I've always been a free speech
absolutist.
Um,
and I think it's,
it's something that's just,
if human dignities to be upheld,
we should be free to express ourselves.
That's just always a basic human right.
Um,
and there is no other country other than
the United States that upholds that
resolutely.
Um,
so doesn't that directly correlate to
everything you do as a secularist and
know what it was like to not be able to
express all those freedoms?
And the reason I prefaced it by saying
that we're all different races and all
that is that we all have the same
opportunity here.
Right?
Exactly.
But,
but people don't lift,
don't like,
if you say American,
do you believe in American
exceptionalism?
That's a good question.
Actually.
I haven't thought about it that I'm
putting you on the spot here.
Now we're going to get the left to hate
you even more.
Yeah.
Well,
I,
I think honestly that good job
interview,
but I think I do.
I mean it's really depends on what you
mean by it.
People from all over the world.
I mean,
I live in New York City and uh,
I can see people from tons of living
together for the most part peacefully
and trying living under one system,
one umbrella.
Yes.
I mean,
I think it's a wonderful idea.
I think America itself is a wonderful
idea is that despite the fact that
obviously the history of it was not as
beautiful as it as I wish it to be.
But I mean Jefferson,
who was one of my heroes called America,
the kind of experiments is that let's
put these values and see how they work
together.
I think for the most part to a great
experiments that this concept of the new
world of,
of the,
of the American constitution is that one
of the first documents I was translated
when I was in Iraq and trying to
suppress the flyers around was the bill
of rights of the United States.
For me it's like my Bible is like one of
the most important because during the
time that it came from obviously,
I mean now we take it for granted.
People say like freedom of speech.
It's a human life.
But before this concept of,
of separation of powers and separation
of church and state.
So for me like the most important things
about the American constitution,
these are used to be radical ideas back
at the time and established this nation
of from people all over the world.
And here we are.
I don't think this.
This kind of happened in medical news
around the plant and the three of us
from different parts of the wall to have
a different culture or background can
come together and have a discussion
about ideas.
And that's,
that's the power of ideas.
And I love that you brought up Thomas
Jefferson in this because about a year
ago I was at cello,
which was his home.
He Got Regina.
Yeah,
that's great.
And it's a great place and they tell his
story and it's really interesting
because progress takes time so that they
taught,
he looked.
This is a man who owned slaves.
Not only did he owned slaves,
he had relations with at least one,
I think several of the women.
So he was in effect having sex with his
slaves.
So obviously something's not.
I mean that's not right on many in terms
of slavery and women's rights and a
zillion reasons,
but at the same time he was doing so
much good for the country and so many of
the ideas he had lead to goodness.
So it shows that not everything is
through that kernel of evil.
You want to find the goodness in people.
Yes,
but and,
and,
but there is a trend nowadays to apply
modern moral framework to look at the
past and you're starting to see that
with Oxford Rhodes must fall campaign
and things like that.
We're looking back into the past and now
faulting,
you know,
leader,
certainly in the history,
um,
for,
for views they had.
So
how dangerous do you think that is as
someone who's sort of in the academic
world?
I mean,
I,
I find that to be incredibly dangerous.
We're going to look back on everybody
one day as,
as culture changes.
We're going to look back on everybody
and go APP that.
Well see he was a homophobe right?
Yeah.
Although I think he actually said
something that I should be able to get
married or something to that effect.
We will be able to do that to everybody.
Yeah,
it,
it's,
you know,
starting on campus.
Right?
So what Joel Wilson School,
and I'm at a university there,
they're debating removing his name.
Um,
the question is again,
it ultimately comes down to why do you
feel like that helps,
you know,
is it,
is it something that's a personal,
it doesn't feel like a personal attack.
And,
and if we,
if we weigh out every single person with
that kind of moral calculus,
you're not gonna you're really not going
to find any.
Um,
uh,
any ideal person,
in the past,
right,
right.
There's literally nobody,
and that's why I keep saying the left
just eats itself.
I've seen this over and over.
Unless your APP.
Look,
we can see the way sometimes even with
Bernie,
they've turned on Bernie a little bit
with some of the race issues with black
lives matter and it's like here's a guy
who was arrested in the,
in the sixties,
you're standing up against segregation
and things like that.
So it's like you have to have a better
set of principles than something that'll
just come around and get you on day.
Yeah.
They also talk about history.
I mean they're also nice to look at the
context and the timing.
I mean if,
if Jefferson wanted slavery to be part
of the United States,
he will have written into the
constitution.
So obviously,
I mean the guy was sophisticated enough
that it takes time to understand what
diverse in.
But yeah,
when it comes to mind reading,
this seems like a pretty good over
there.
Yeah.
It also shows,
I guess that we have personal short
falls that you can somehow maybe in the
public be better than you are
personally.
Right.
So he's writing all of these things
about equality for man clearly led the
groundwork for you,
the slaves,
right?
Yeah.
And yet at the same time,
at the personal level he didn't.
So yeah,
certainly component.
You're talking about an hour,
like bringing the conversation to
global.
Is that like for example,
like as I work in the human rights
field,
I mean I would be honest like for starch
in Saudi Arabia,
I'm not going to advocate for same sex
marriage,
but our advocate,
the concept that gays are human beings
equal equal rights and then you can
build a foundation that over time,
of course,
I mean I,
I saw Mike based upon many of
Jefferson's readings and,
and back to the eight,
the life eating itself is like,
there was this congressman,
he's also was a civil rights icon.
Lewis.
His last name is Louis.
I forgot who endorsed Hillary Clinton.
John Lewis.
Yes.
So I'm in.
I,
I'm not,
I cannot avoid this election shot.
I can bash any candidate I want,
so what happened when he endorsed
Hillary?
But if somebody I agree with or don't,
that's irrelevant.
The amount of attacks that he got from
the far left was pretty impressive about
how they are anti racist.
They were calling him pretty racist
terms,
uncle Tom and word and overall all of
that because he endorsed a candidate
they didn't like this is itself the LF
eating itself because they supposedly
and direct service,
but there is still on their side of the
ticket.
Yeah.
There was a quote from Fdr that I really
like.
It was.
He asked him why do you support the
fascist in Nicaragua?
He,
they said he's a son of a bitch but is
our self.
So,
so if,
if,
uh,
Mr Lewis and drove the car day like
that,
he is okay.
That is what that black person should
vote for.
But if not,
then he is thing to talk about.
Uh,
they,
they claim to be.
I mean there is a new term called the
entire racists racists,
which is interesting.
Yeah.
And I have double negative but,
and also have to work this through at
home.
And also there's the Islamophobia phobia
of the fear of being perceived as
Islamophobic is,
is now selected.
They are afraid of being perceived as
level four,
a big advocate for as low phobia.
I,
there's no doubt that that was all
right.
We have to wrap up here.
So I'm going to give you the last word.
What can we do?
What is the number one thing we can do
to help these ideas spread?
So what Phase I was saying about the
outreach he wishes to divert the,
the,
the outrage manufactured by all these
small little incursions into global
issues.
Um,
I think that's actually something that
he's working on on movements and it's a
very worthwhile cause because with that
we can engage people who do live in
western democracies to be more active
and to be more aware of the perspective
of what's going on with the persecution
that's going on in closed societies.
So that's for me very.
I'm a very key thing.
Yeah.
And while we have our power of freedom,
we may as well use it.
Right.
Alright.
Well I have a feeling we're going to
continue this in the green room because
we barely.
I didn't even pick this thing up.
All right.
Uh,
well for more of the work that Faisal
and Melissa do,
check out the global secular humanist
movement on facebook.
Go to movements.org.
And thank you guys for watching.
I will do it again next week.